Good evening and welcome to the LangFocus Channel.
This is a quick video to bring you some breaking news from the linguistic world.
According to recently released documents.
The E.U. will soon be adopting Esperanto as an official language.
For those who don't know, Esperanto Is a constructed language that was created in the 1870s by doctor L. L. Zamenhof.
It was created in order to function as an international auxiliary language that people all around the world can learn.
And it was intentionally designed to be extremely easy to learn.
But Esperanto never fully caught on and remained mostly a hobby for language nerds.
UNTIL NOW.
According to E.U officials, Esperanto will be designated the 25th official language of the E.U.
and will function as a working language  of the european parliament,
as a procedural language of the European Commission,
in addition to English, French and German